Đây là giọng bài gân nó sôi ra một giống đến hình trong lời kỳ giật kiếp tự
Công thay thành hiểu xô bản chết và nắng chính từ vý qua bài bản sau đây
Hay bệnh khô mà về cái nhau mấy đáng khi lúc mẹ theo đúng thạm
Ờ, nhưng mà chúng ta không giòn xô mấy là như bài tróa mà
Bình bì chắc sắn giữ khi sẽ xong bùa
Bây giờ, lấy viên lưu là hay bệnh nhau
Hay bệnh xô bà về cho, nó có cái nấu chuyện nó có tóc có đúng là xong bùi xói hay
Hãy cho nó mấy xô bùi xong nước
Thì bài tôi luật rất gặp làm cái giống như đời
2,5 mìs sẽ chắc ca đúng rồi
Hay là mình cho nó là thấy bây giờ loại làm gì vậy?
Thì bây giờ mà mình giữa l snaps để bầu được chuyện cho
Rồi thì cái giống bây giờ mình sẽ cùng di đây
Làm cái đáng伬 là có tóc cả nấu sui, giống nước là sẽ tuyệt có lúc slậm
Chúng là nó mình giữa ác mấy do
Và tôi luật gặp nước, với bào nó là bằng bùi xói
Rồi làm em thì có mình giữa gặp nhau
Chúng ta có vô tí xôi cọng
Tổ thung tí đó
Nhai đó là quả dầu đó
Lô tí kì đó
các bạn mới đặt ra và nha đấu tí là cái đôi dầu đi xôi dọng
Búng không!
Tí tí xôi dọng là cái gì đó
Khi tý xôi đó là dí đe
Này 1 2 cũng không với hai bạn
Búng không?
thì có 1 tui thuộc đường
và v một vài mình cho quả
khi các bạn bộ lượng của thông hợp
nó sẽ bọng bọng 2, bọng 2, bọng 1, bọng 2
thì chết nhặt
thì mình là vui 1, 2, 1, 2, 1, 2, 3
Bây giờ, mấy cái lạc khi mà người gà này.
Cái gì khi đó?
Cái khi người gà mà thì vê mùa thai, xây làm sao?
Ngược chuyện của vê hai bai.
Bà quan hửa xuy ra vê mùa bà sông đi qua.
Vê mùa thai, trị vê hai bai.
Đúng không?
Bà xây làm cho bà là lấy mùi xói phở hai, trị mùa thai.
Nhưng không?
Bói mùa phai ra.
Dí lùa mê thì rồi.
Bà trởi mùa phai tạm, trởi mùi phai tạm.
Bây giờ mình biết cái chiếc bài nữa
thì sẽ hợp được bài bài bài đâu kiểu